comment trouver des financements quand
on est une association c'était la
thématique d'un forum organisé à la
maison de l'environnement à magny les
hameaux
à l'occasion du mois de l'économie
sociale et solidaire une forme
d'économie responsable qui concerne 9,5
pour cent des entreprises de france et
plus de 10% des salariés parmi les
acteurs présents deux structures
départementales qui accompagnent des
associations dans leur développement
comment rechercher des subventions et
les comment les pérenniser
puisque aujourd'hui avec la baisse des
subventions aux associations doivent
réfléchir aussi à d'autres sources de
financement énormément selon sur l'art
la recherche de subventions diversifier
les sources de financement
le contexte de la crise touche également
les et surtout les structures de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
autres conseils bien remplir les
dossiers de demande de financement
auprès des structures publiques pour
multiplier ses chances
de nombreux rendez vous sont à retrouver
dans les yvelines jusqu'à fin novembre
toutes les informations sont sur le site
du mois de l'économie sociale et
solidaire